the Joe Rogan experience how much you
think Deontay Wilder won this weekend I
don't know but the way he's winning this
got to be it's got to be something
special
I hope it's gotta be he's heavyweight
world champion yes I would I would hope
but well the interesting thing too is
the this tournament that's involves
unofficial tournament right because what
do we have are we a week or so away from
the rematch between Andy Ruiz and
Anthony Joshua it's got to be coming up
somewhat I think it's about a week I
think it's next weekend mmm Joshua looks
so good in training and and Ruiz man you
can't judge that guy on his belly
you have nothing if you think that's
what it is you think that's what
fighting is do you guys have a tissue
somewhere sorry man it was like his
thank you
his hands are spectacular the fluidity
of his combinations it's gorgeous man
it's been rocky oh he's so good I love
watch that guy throw combinations and
when he fought Joshua that was the thing
was he if he hit him once
he's gonna hit him 13 14 15 times after
that bang bang and the hands are like a
middleweights hands I mean he's so fast
he moves he moves beautifully takes a
shot great two and he's such a like a
sweet unassuming guy like he wins the
title and you're like [ __ ] yeah are you
happy for him he's such a nice guy man
but do you think yeah Joshua
underestimated him
well the word is and this is from people
that that really know what's going on
this is I mean I can't give specifics
but apparently Joshua got knocked out in
training oh really yes like a couple
weeks out like bang and that's one of
the reasons why they say his father was
so furious at the promoter after Ruiz
knocked him out and it's also one of the
reasons they said that he had some sort
of a panic attack in the locker room
leading up to the fight mm-hmm so if he
was compromised any news compromised you
know and you know as well as anybody
there's certain knockouts you can get in
the gym that can [ __ ] a fighter up for
months oh yeah of course
yeah I've seen it that's why in the
practice room I don't like rough
training I don't like rough training
like certain fighters who are coming up
to a fight I'll let it go further I get
it we need the intensities
but I don't like to go in the gym and
see this guy knocked out this guy then
this guy knocked out this guy and then
what happens you go in the practice room
there's nobody there the next week for
sparring the sparring has to be
practiced not fighting right so if I had
a world champion any sparring and I felt
one of his sparring partners was out of
control I would definitely talk with him
or not use him anymore
like when George when George spars I
pick all his rounds but they have to be
they have to be reasonable rounds not
naught and I mean not touch sparring but
not also being malicious and trying to
injure each other but George told me
that you told certain guys to try to
knock him out yes yeah that's true also
I put a bounty on him as well because
the guys at one point he was too famous
nobody wanted to touch him no more it
was too low Oh put him on the ground I'm
gonna Twitter it for you your tinder is
gonna explode you're gonna become famous
are you gonna be the number one man on
to it tinder everybody's swiping right
for you yes be done like I pumped them
up because they're to the hots GSP right
right you know that so there's a balance
there's not there's too little and then
there's too much you know so I mean if
you're trying to like throw vicious
knees when you know like if you if I see
you're trying to be rough overly rough
because there's a control you know if I
touch you I'm gonna back off if I hurt
you but if I touch it now I'm trying to
need you and kick you and I'm trying to
like right that's like hey this guy's
and the thing is with George sometimes
I'll keep a guy fresh so he'll be he'll
be two rounds in then I put in a fresh
guy so that first guy has to have some
control as well because George is tired
now
you know he's fatigued and etc so I mean
there's a balance there's too little and
there's too much so if you if you get
knocked out in practice before a title
fight it could be an accidental but it
calls to be negligence I guys are just
too rough cuz sometimes you do go in
boxing gyms and it's like kill or be
killed yes that's the attitude yeah well
it's a lot of MMA gyms as well I agree
it's um it's very unfortunate because a
lot of people they ruin their career
inside the gym because they're sparring
not just once a week but twice three
times a week and they're going in they
might get concussed the might get
concussed on Tuesday and spar again on
Thursday and that's very very common
absolutely and there's no regulation no
one's stopping you from sparring if you
got head kick tomorrow no one's stopping
you from showing up on Saturday and put
your mouthpiece in and going into class
it's just it's nuts it's not say it's
[Applause]